qui permettent de deviner, ou de prévoir l'objet d'un appel
avant même de décrocher le téléphone.
C'est grâce à un apport d'intelligence dans un procédé
qui a longtemps été considéré comme une impasse en occident.
Et le dernier type d'innovation, d'innovation invisible, produite en Inde,
est ce que nous appelons le management innovant.
Ce n'est pas un nouveau produit, ni un nouveau procédé,
mais une nouvelle façon d'organiser le travail,
et le management innovant le plus significatif venu d'Inde,
inventé par les entreprises indiennes qui délocalisent,
est ce que nous appelons le modèle mondial de prestation de service.
Le modèle mondial de prestation de service permet
de prendre des tâches qui autrefois étaient concentrées géographiquement,
de les diviser en plusieurs parties, de les distribuer partout dans le monde,
là où les compétences et les structures de coût existent,
puis de préciser les moyens de les intégrer à nouveau.
Sans cela, on ne pourrait avoir aujourd'hui
aucun des autres types d'innovation.
Ce que j'essaie de dire, ce que nos recherchent montrent,
c'est que si le produit destiné à l'utilisateur final
est la pointe émergée de l'iceberg de l'innovation,
l'Inde est bien présente dans la partie la plus vaste,
invisible et submergée, de l'iceberg de l’innovation.
Bien sûr, il y a des conséquences,
nous avons développé trois implications découlant de nos recherches.
La première est ce que nous appelons l'échelle des compétences plongeante,
et je vais maintenant revenir au point de départ de ma conversation avec vous,
qui était la question de la fuite des emplois.
Bien sûr, en tant que multinationale,
quand on décide de délocaliser des emplois de R&D en Inde,
on délocalise tout d'abord le premier échelon,
les emplois les moins sophistiqués,
précisément comme Tom Friedman l'aurait prédit.
Ce qui arrive alors, si vous délocalisez vers l'Inde le premier échelon
du travail d'innovation et de R&D,
c'est qu'à un certain moment, dans un futur proche,
vous rencontrez un problème,
qui est, d'où proviennent les personnes
situées sur l'échelon suivant, au sein de votre société ?
Vous avez alors deux possibilités :
Soit vous amenez des gens de l'Inde dans le monde développé
pour occuper l'échelon suivant,
- l'immigration -
soit vous vous dites, il y a tellement de gens en Inde
prêts à occuper l'échelon suivant,
pourquoi ne pas déplacer aussi celui-là en Inde ?
Ce qu'on essaye de dire, c'est que
une fois que vous délocalisez le bas de l'échelle,
c'est un geste qui s'auto-entretient, à cause de l'échelle des compétences plongeante,
ce qui signifie simplement
que l'on ne peut pas être un banquier d'investissement
sans avoir été auparavant un analyste.
On ne peut pas être un professeur sans avoir été étudiant.
On ne peut pas être un consultant sans avoir été un adjoint de recherche.
ainsi, si l'on délocalise les emplois les moins sophistiqués,
tôt ou tard, l'échelon suivant devra suivre.
Le deuxième point que nous soulevons, est ce que nous appelons
le brunissement des EMS, les équipes de management supérieures.
Si les compétences en R&D sont basées en Inde et en Chine,
et que les marchés à plus forte croissance
sont basés en Inde et en Chine,
il faudra se résoudre à ce que
le management supérieur du futur
vienne d'Inde ou de Chine,
parce que c'est là où se trouvent les principaux produits,
c'est là où se trouvent les principaux marchés importants.
Ok ? La dernière chose que nous soulignons dans cette diapo,
c'est qu'il y a une mise en garde dans cette histoire, vous voyez.
L’Inde a la population la plus jeune et la plus croissante du monde.
Cette rente démographique est extraordinaire, mais paradoxalement,
elle recèle l'illusion d'un puissant réservoir de main d’œuvre.
Les instituts et le système éducatif indiens,
à quelques exceptions près, sont incapables de produire des étudiants
en quantité et en qualité suffisantes
pour maintenir en mouvement ce moteur de l'innovation,
alors les sociétés trouvent des façons innovantes de surmonter le problème,
mais au final cela ne dégage pas le gouvernement de sa responsabilité
dans la création de cette structure éducative.
Pour finir, je voudrais conclure
en vous montrant le profil d'une société, IBM.
Comme vous le savez sans doute, IBM a toujours été considéré
comme l'une des sociétés les plus innovantes
de ces cent dernières années.
En fait, si vous prenez le nombre de brevets déposés au cours de son histoire,
je crois qu'elle est la première, ou dans les deux ou trois premières sociétés au monde
en ce qui concerne les brevets déposés aux États-Unis par une société privée.
Voici le profil des employés d'IBM
au cours de la dernière décennie.
En 2003, il y avait 300 000 salariés,
ou 330 000 salariés, parmi lesquels 135 000 étaient en Amérique,
et 9 000 étaient en Inde.
Il y avait 400 000 salariés en 2009, date à laquelle
les salariés américains avaient baissé à 105 000,
tandis que les employés indiens étaient montés à 100 000.
Eh bien, en 2010, ils ont décidé de ne plus révéler ces chiffres,
j'ai donc dû faire des estimations
en me basant sur différentes sources.
Voici mes meilleures estimations, ok ?
Je ne dis pas que ce sont les nombres exacts, c'est juste une estimation.
Cela donne une idée de la tendance.
Il y a 433 000 personnes aujourd'hui chez IBM,
dont 98 000 sont encore aux États-Unis,
et 150 000 sont en Inde.
A vous de me dire, IBM est-elle une société américaine,
ou une société indienne ? (Rires)
Mesdames et Messieurs, merci beaucoup. (Applaudissements)